listen the last time I saw you you told
me you were gonna slow down you have not
slow down honey it hasn't slowed down
I'm back in the studio which is a really
good thing and then it's I guess
managing all the craziness around it I'm
happy I'm like coming to the end of my
three-year tour this month yeah also
getting to do all the jingle balls is
really exciting because I've never had
the chance to do them in the US and
Canada and yeah it's it's just been such
a fun ride and this feels like a really
nice way to cap off this album cycle in
this campaign and to get ready for 2019
yeah 2019 your new album I remember
you're talking about that yeah the final
touches on it yeah are you happy with it
are you excited I'm still writing I'm
really excited I'm a little bit nervous
but they're the same feelings that I got
when I was preparing my first album that
I'm getting them again because I'm like
oh my god it's you're going back into
that process of like creating something
and it being for you to begin with and
then slowly you start thinking about
what my fans are gonna like or how
they're gonna respond to it or how
they're gonna feel about it and it gets
really exciting and so I'm
I'm very much looking forward yeah do
you have a name for it yet I do but I
can't tell you it's a one word it's to
us it's two words
what could the two words mean I could
try to figure it out there's two words
but it's it's it's a conceptual album
yes so those two words will tell you
what the concept is and so much success
right now the first I guess you're the
second female now to have 1 billion
streams on Spotify yeah it's it's crazy
how did you find out my friends on
Twitter but they're always supposed to
kind of let me know about any crazy
milestones um which I'm so grateful for
cuz I try and like stay away from like
looking at numbers yeah trying to
compare myself or my songs to anything
else but I I feel so lucky that my fans
are always just like they're always
supporting me and they're always sending
me messages and they're always the first
to let me know and like exciting things
happen so I'm really grateful it's such
a good feeling and it's also crazy
because that's a lot of ears and a lot
of times people have listened to it and
yeah I'm I'm really I'm really happy
about it we have one question from the
fans can I ask for a quick question or
yeah yeah because lottery fans were
asking about your collaborations with
Andrea Bocelli and Calvin Harris and
having two different types of music and
extreme is it a different experience
both times it is a different experience
it's also something that I try to think
about quite consciously as working with
people that don't necessarily make the
same kind of music that I do and that's
what makes it exciting and that's what
kind of pushes me to try different
things because I'm like oh well if
people were kind of into songs that they
did wouldn't necessarily think would
come from me it allows me more leeway to
kind of be more creative and play around
with different sounds and do something
different so I'm really really excited
I'm so excited for you I'm gonna be home
with the family
yeah favorite Christmas song Oh Mariah
you